Before we get into the reasons why his work is so important--
let's take a minute to try to put ourselves in Newton's shoes
and imagine what his life was like.
So, here we are, leaning against an apple tree reading one of our favorite books,
and all around us things are happening.
Apples are falling off trees. Rocks are rolling down mountains.
And as nature unfolds around it, we probably never really stop to ask what's happening.
We just take it for granted.
If we want to think about something profound, maybe we look at the moon or the stars or the sun.
Surely, the motions of these perfect celestial bodies are somehow more perfect
or different than the motions of commonplace items like apples and rocks.
Now, with the benefit of hindsight, I'm going to ask you a question.
What do the motions of stars and apples have in common?
Do they have nothing in common at all? Are they totally distinct and separate?
Or are these motions completely identical?
Or are they somehow different but governed by the same set of laws?
Which means that the same rules which affect how an apple falls to the ground
also affect how the earth orbits the sun or the moon orbits the earth.
I haven't taught you this yet, so I don't expect you to know the answer,
but I do want to get you thinking. Choose what you think is the best answer.